en este vídeo veremos los sustratos
primarios y trataremos de saber si es
una reacción de sustitución o de
eliminación
entonces para este alumno de alquilo
primario sabemos que no es una reacción
sn 1 porque para esa reacción
necesitamos un kart vocación estable y
no podemos obtener uno con este alumno
de alquilo primario ahora una reacción
sn 2 si es posible porque en un alumno
de alquilo primario tenemos poco
impedimento estético y por otro lado no
es una reacción 1 por la misma razón que
no es s n 1 no podemos formar un kart
vocación estable pero una reacción
mediante el mecanismo 2 si es posible ok
ahora el siguiente paso es analizar el
reactivo vamos a ver en esta reacción
tenemos un núcleo filo de azufre porque
solamente actuará como un núcleo filo y
no como una base entonces si actúa como
un núcleo filo eso significa que la
reacción es 2 queda afuera porque
damos una base fuerte para una reacción
es 2 por lo tanto esta es una reacción
que ocurre mediante el mecanismo sn 2 y
sabemos que es un mecanismo concertado
es decir el núcleo filo ataca al electro
filo al mismo tiempo que se va el grupo
saliente entonces formamos un enlace
entre el azufre y este carbono de color
rojo al mismo tiempo que estos
electrones se van junto con el yodo para
formar el año en yoduro dibujemos el
producto final
aquí tenemos 4 carbonos y ahora tenemos
un enlace con el azufre con un hidrógeno
y el carbono rojo sería este carbono
este es nuestro producto y no tenemos
que preocuparnos por la stereo química
porque no tenemos ningún centro gira
nuevamente tenemos una luro de alquilo
primario y ya vimos que no ocurre en los
mecanismos de reacción sn 1 y 1 así que
solo necesitamos decidir entre s n 2 y
el 2 si analizamos el reactivo sabemos
que él debe n es una base fuerte por lo
tanto esta reacción ocurre mediante el
mecanismo de 2 no mediante ese n 2 el de
vn tiene que funcionar como una base
fuerte y bueno aquí podemos ver que el
halógeno está unido a un carbono ese
debe ser nuestro carbono alfa y en un
mecanismo 2 tomamos un protón del
carbono beta entonces este es el carbono
beta y aquí tenemos un hidrógeno unido a
este carbono beta y sabemos que el de vn
es una base neutra la dibujaré por aquí
como una base general con su par de
electrones libres así que esta base toma
este protón con lo que estos electrones
se mueven hacia acá al mismo tiempo que
estos electrones se van junto con el
yodo para formar el año en yoduro
dibujemos el producto final tenemos la
cadena de carbonos
aquí tenemos el doble enlace y ahora se
formó un doble enlace aquí resaltemos
los electrones estos electrones de color
rosa se movieron para formar el doble
enlace para este alumno de alquilo
primario ya sabemos que los mecanismos
sn 1 y 1 están fuera así que necesitamos
decidir entre s n 2 y el 2 entonces
observemos el reactivo aquí tenemos
hidróxido de potasio y sabemos que el
ión hidróxido es un núcleo filo fuerte y
una base fuerte esa es la categoría que
vimos en el vídeo anterior y bueno como
en una luro del kilo primario no hay
impedimento estético la reacción sn 2
gana así que un núcleo filo pequeño
puede atacar a este carbono al mismo
tiempo que estos electrones se van junto
con el bromo para formar el año en
bromuro entonces este es nuestro carbono
de color rojo vamos a dibujar la cadena
de carbono
aquí tenemos 5 carbonos y este es el
carbono rojo y unido a este carbono
tenemos nuestro
así que formamos un alcohol mediante una
reacción sn 2 en este alumno de alquilo
primario nuevamente tenemos que decidir
entre s n 2 y 2 como reactivo tenemos
debut óxido de potasio y esto se parece
mucho al problema anterior en el que
teníamos hidróxido de potasio porque
tenemos una carga negativa en este
oxígeno así que podríamos pensar que
puede actuar como un núcleo filo y que
es una base fuerte pero el tributo óxido
de potasio tiene impedimento estético
por este grupo que tenemos aquí y como
tiene impedimento estético no puede
actuar como un núcleo filo así que no es
una reacción sn 2 por lo tanto debe ser
una reacción y 2 voy a dibujar el alumno
de alquiló por aquí para que podamos
verlo mejor y pondré el bromo hacia
abajo
ok sabemos que el carbono que se
encuentra directamente unido al bromo es
el carbono alfa y el carbono unido al
carbono alfa es el carbono petta
entonces ese es nuestro carbono beta y
tenemos dos hidrógenos beta pero solo
dibujaré uno ok y sabemos que en un
mecanismo 2 la base fuerte toma un
protón beta entonces la base toma este
protón al mismo tiempo que estos
electrones se mueven hacia acá y estos
electrones se mueven para formar el yom
bromuro dibujemos el producto final aquí
tenemos los carbonos tenemos 5 carbonos
y después tenemos un doble enlace entre
estos dos carbonos entonces los
electrones de color rosa se movieron
hacia acá para formar el doble enlace
para el último ejemplo veamos al bromuro
de tilo reaccionando con agua sabemos
que no es sn 1 ni 1 así que solo tenemos
que decidir entre s n 2 y el 2 ahora
sabemos que el agua es un núcleo filo
débil pero también es una base débil
entonces como el agua es una base débil
la reacción es 2 queda afuera así que
debe de ser la reacción sn 2 entonces el
núcleo filo ataca al alumno de alquilo y
se forma un enlace entre el oxígeno y
este carbono de color rojo y esto ocurre
al mismo tiempo que estos electrones se
van junto con el bromo para formar el a
neón bromuro entonces dibujemos el
resultado el oxígeno formó un enlace con
el carbono rojo un par de electrones
libres en el oxígeno vamos a ponerlos de
color rosa formaron este enlace y el
oxígeno aún está unido a dos hidrógenos
dibujemos los hidrógenos y aún tenemos
un par de electrones libres en el
oxígeno todo eso le da al oxígeno una
carga formal positiva y finalmente para
obtener el producto neutro sólo
necesitamos des protón ar entonces otra
molécula de agua entra y actúa como una
base y supongamos que toma este protón
dejando estos electrones con el oxígeno
así obtenemos el producto final aquí
tenemos un h formamos etanol ahora esta
reacción necesita mucho calor y mucho
tiempo así que no es exactamente la
reacción más práctica porque una
reacción sn dos necesita un núcleo filo
fuerte y el agua no es tan buen núcleo
filo entonces como esta reacción es muy
lenta tal vez en algunos libros se
encuentren que esta reacción no sucede
porque no es muy práctica